Olympic gold-medalist Aly Raisman is
suing the US Olympic Committee and USA
Gymnastics for their alleged role in the
Larry Nasser sexual abuse case in the
lawsuit she claims both organizations
could have done more to stop the former
doctors abuse that suit comes on the
same day that a male gymnast alleged in
a different lawsuit that NASA abused him
and Warner's here with new information
revealed in the lawsuits for the first
time and a good morning good morning
more than 260 women and girls have
accused Nasser of sexual abuse but Jacob
Moore is the first alleged male victim
to join a suit against Nasser Moore
claims he went to the former doctor for
a shoulder injury in 2016 and was
sexually abused and harassed my whole
family was fooled by you former US
national team gymnast Cameron Moore told
a courtroom in January she and her
brother Jacob were sexually abused by
Larry Nasser abuse he disguised as
medical treatment
you put acupuncture needles right next
to his genitals Jacob Moore who is now a
freshman gymnast at the University of
Michigan joined his sister in a federal
lawsuit Wednesday against Nasser USA
Gymnastics and Michigan State University
where Nasser worked the lawsuit alleges
in 2016 Nasser brought Jacob to his
basement and treated his shoulder injury
with acupuncture in his pubic area and
in and around his genitalia the suit
also alleges Nasser pulled down Moore's
pants exposing his genitalia to an
underage female gymnast how are we to
believe in change when these
organizations aren't even willing to
acknowledge the problem Olympic gymnast
Aly Raisman also filed a suit Wednesday
in California alleging the sexual abuse
she suffered at the hands of Nasser
could have been prevented at USA
Gymnastics and the US Olympic Committee
taken the mandate of her safety
seriously she claimed the organization's
put their quest for money and medals
above her safety and the safety of other
minor competitive athletes Raisman made
those thoughts clear at Nasser's
sentencing in January in both USA
Gymnastics and the United States Olympic
Committee have been very quick to
capitalize and celebrate my success but
did they reach out when
I came forward No on Wednesday the US
Olympic Committee said its CEO Scott
Blackmun is stepping down it also
announced reforms to help protect
athletes from abuse we reached out to
the u.s. Olympic Committee USA
Gymnastics and Michigan State University
for a response to these new lawsuits but
we have not heard back Anna thanks